the term woke simply meant I've become
aware
of causes of social justice that I can
support through activism that's all it
means oh I learned about the fact that
uh uh public transit can be used in a
discriminatory way I've become woke to
that now I understand that that's an
issue maybe I want to do something about
it that's what woke initially meant we
might challenge a status quo or we might
fight some kind of Oppression and it's
all to create a better world that's what
it meant okay now Republicans when they
say woke
it it's a shorthand for any idea or
policy I don't like that's on the left
okay that's one version of it or also
it's a sort of conversation stopper the
same way that sometimes people say
that's offensive oh but that's woke
nonsense that's fundamentally what it is